elles se sont rencontrés voilà vingt ans
dans un atelier de peinture de
techniques anciennes
le chantier de restauration d'un salon
du 19e siècle du musée national de port
royal des champs à magny les hameaux
l occasion pour sophie et eliette
d'allier leurs talents pour la première
fois et de mêlée restauration et
approches d'un chantier traditionnels ce
sont des chantiers qui à l'époque était
valverde peintre en décor donc jelal
approche pratique du deux chantiers
finalement donc là la restauration est
un petit peu particulière dans la mesure
où on a eu un côté restauration toute
une partie restauration qui quand même
du concert depuis la moitié du salon et
une partie restitution puisque l'on a
découvert que ce salon avait été
restitué déjà au 19e siècle
le chantier a débuté par la
réintégration pictural en octobre 2012
mais les premières peintures ont été
découvertes et nettoyer il y a plus de
trois ans tels deux archéologues sophie
eliette ont découvert leurs différentes
couches successives en remontant dans le
temps jusqu'à découvrir la teinte
originale du xviiie siècle patiner
presque bronze à cause de l'oxydation et
divers traitements aux huiles et occire
redécouvrir la couleur originale ne fut
pas chose aisée les peintures de dessus
de porte ont largement renseigner nos
deux expertes
non
je suis en train d'appliquer une
troisième couche il à la couche de
peinture verte fâchent à la colle de
peau vous a été réalisé avec des
pigments de l'aco dépôt pour réintégrer
c'est à dire pour eux re donner
l'illusion de l'ensemble alors bien
entendu ne déborde pas sur la peinture
originale que l'on a conservé les
tableaux entièrement re marouflé sur un
nid d'abeille conservent leur plastique
de protection pour éviter les coulures
le salon à l'un des derniers des corses
anciens du musée qui n'avait pas encore
été restauré l'opération devrait
s'achever au printemps le salon
accueillera les premiers visiteurs pour
la nuit des musées en mai 2013
d'ici là seule plume peut-on profiter